si l'alerte a été levée bien l'heure est
maintenant
à au fait que il faut porter secours aux
personnes qui se trouve sous les débris
je suis ici dans le quartier de
solomianski qui a été durement touché
vous entendez sans doute à côté de moi
le bruit d'une pompe à eau des pompiers
qui tentent encore d'éteindre le feu
provoqué par des débris de missile on va
voir sur ce bâtiment ici qui a été
durement touché vous voyez qu'il s'agit
d'un immeuble résidentiel un bâtiment où
se trouvaient des Ukrainiens donc tôt ce
matin qui ont été surpris par ces frappe
le bilan que vous avez annoncé d'un mort
et bien il s'est alourdi il y a deux
morts à présent l'un d'eux est une
personne âgée une une dame âgée qui est
morte dans l'ambulance qui la conduisait
à l'hôpital il y a des dizaines de
blessés ici à kiief donc les secours
sont sur place ce n'est pas le seul site
dans la capitale avoir été avoir été
visé il y a des colonnes de fumées noir
un peu partout dans la ville et la ville
de halkif dans le nord-est du pays a
également été touché on y compte plus de
40 blessés également beaucoup de dégâts
matériels et je reviendrai juste sur
cette menace de Vladimir Poutine cette
menace il la met à exécution depuis
bientôt 2 ans ce n'est pas nouveau ça ne
date pas de la frappe sur Belgorod et ce
genre de frappe à l'aide de missiles
hypersoniqu de type kinjan des des des
missiles qui frappe des infrastructures
civiles des infrastructures énergétiques
ce genre de frappe et bien il faut des
semaines des mois pour les préparer donc
ça n'a rien à voir avec la frappe de
Belgorod c'est tout simplement la
continuité des frappes qui tous les
jours frappent l'Ukraine principalement
dans l'est du pays mais au cours de
l'hiver et surtout au cours de ces
derniers jours des frappes qui se sont
intensifiées qui frappent l'ensemble du
euh de du pays qui frappe avant tout les
civils plusieurs plusieurs bâtiments
sont privés d'eau d'électricité
également ce matin dans la capitale
l'heure est au bilan l'heure est au
premiier secours qui sont en train
d'être apportés aux nombreuses victimes